i bitch about wearing makeup and having
to do my hair and put it picking out an
outfit as a woman I really resent it
when I saw Andrews little backpack he
packed for two weeks on the road just a
backpack one backpack it had space in it
like I don't understand having a bag a
small bag and not stuffing it to the
brim but he is like a lot of room in
this backpack it's not even that big of
a bag it's for two weeks of supplies
because he doesn't have makeup and he
goes what do you need that you can live
in solid eight he was really trying to
help me work through it I'm like a hair
dryer and he goes why do you need that
there's hope ones in hotel while I was
like have you ever used a hotel hair
dryer they can't if your hair's gonna
look good you can't have this like wispy
little breath breathing on you and we're
back at you up with Nikki Glaser in
studio now is the hilarious the prolific
Sebastian Maniscalco prolific man for
our specials you have under your belt
your fourth one stay hungry just dropped
today congratulations thank you for
having me on
[Laughter]
she's glowing I know look at the hands
and I went down to the ankle looks good
and I really yeah I've only showered
once since I got it I'm what ever do you
get spray tans I do yeah and do you make
do you try to make them last I do I not
to shower for like 24 there's there's
certain levels you could do there's one
where you could do it you could shower
after three hours there's one you have
to put on 24 hours so I like to like let
it marinate you to my skin a little bit
but
yeah because you gotta plan your life
according to them cuz you're like I got
this TV thing next week it's gonna be
sloughing off by then I can't just throw
another one on top of it I got to take
it off okay so you you do a week prior
that to the TV appearance well let's
let's let's be honest with ourselves I
got the spray tan cuz I'm seeing a guy
who rejected I got two days out I
usually get a spray tan for that perf if
it's if I'm gearing towards something in
two to two days beforehand I'll get it
so is that that perfect glow and then
five days after a spray tan it's
disgusting I just look it's dirty
because it's flaking off I'm glad to
talk to someone who knows this break
absolutely that's the first thing I
noticed do pose in front of the woman
naked and she gets naked no there's no
naked on the spring no no it's it's my
underwear and she goes to town okay so
you got those tan lines
that's awful yeah sometimes I'll leave
on the underwear just to get the tan
line cuz some guys like the tan line
they don't want it they don't want to
pretend like you've just been laying out
naked
I think the tan lines hot I think the
tan lines hide on a spray tan or any
type of tan and needs to Anita yes
it's nice yeah okay so sometimes I'll
leave it on on purpose but uh yesterday
I did a fully nude one it was just weird
standing in front of the strange girl
totally naked and I was like I can't
believe I'm used to this that this is
something I do all the time now that
it's just become part of my life I don't
even know this woman do you ever think
of like what she's going through while
she was doing it yes I always want to go
what's my stacking up I want to know I
want to know her experience but yeah
that's it's a weird job but you must
just get used to it like anything you
must yes like it means people still talk
to us like how do you get up there and
do it how do you memorize all of it I
mean there's all those questions still
about doing comedy of like how do you
remember it all how do you think of
stuff the same kind of questions that I
would ask a spray-tan how do you
remember how do you remember where you
left off how did you get the nerve
what happened in your childhood that led
you to seek validation 13 people no big
deal
sold out three shows on his way to
selling out 1/4 Madison Square Garden
show man
your top and lists everywhere I'm not
gonna bring it up but we all know what
list you were on you're in a movie
that's going to be nominated for many an
Oscar if it hasn't already I don't know
if there's have been out announced yet
Green Book is the name of the movie of a
substantial role in that this is wild
you're it's I mean we've we all know
people that have blown up but this is a
this is a big time for you when did you
feel it when did you go well things are
changing it's been a slow it's been like
a slow boil for me I've been doing this
what 20 years now
I don't even for quite some time we work
together well Newport Kentucky Kentucky
Cincinnati
funny bones but it's in it's in Kentucky
and it was the first time I'd ever met
you and you never know what its gonna be
like when you just our feature act
getting plugged into places and you you
show up and there's a headliner and you
were so nice so cool
so easy to talk to I just remember
having a great conversation with you in
the greenroom where I was like I like
that guy like I just he didn't hit up
nothing you would you didn't hit on me
you didn't do anything we didn't say a
one weird thing you were just you were
you're one of very few on a list that
isn't was not weird at all was cool yeah
you you made me feel funny you were
funny it was just it was a great
interaction and I've never forgotten it
and I've always been a fan of your sense
and I appreciate that that's sweet of
you I mean I had a great time with you
that weekend and and yeah I mean it for
me it's been weekend's like that going
to Cincinnati going to Atlanta what have
you just building the audience over time
I really have no TV or movie experience
to speak of I mean there's not been one
hot TV show that kind of catapulted me
into where I am today it's just been
kind of hitting the ground the one
stand-up comedy over the years and
gradually you know more people come more
people come and
and now we're doing Madison Square
Garden and never been it was never in my
first of all I don't have like a dream
board or a vision board I don't write
down goals my goal was to simply make a
living doing stand-up comedy and and you
know just I think what I'm talking about
in my act is my family and I think
people are relating to family and
immigrant background I come from an
Italian family don't have to be Italian
to get the material but I think they're
resonating with the relationship I have
with my father and what I'm seeing or
what I've seen in the last 10 years at
the club's was people would come and
then they would bring their neighbors
next time they would come and then you
know they would bring their and then
busses were pulling up of like the
neighbourhood like would you grow up in
our neighborhood you talking like we
thought you know like so it it was a
slow build yeah and here we are so I I
love that that you say that because
people do feel very connected when
watching you and they feel like when
they discover you they've discovered you
I mean I just heard you on Stern and
he's like I thought I discovered this
guy I thought that I was the one that
found him and turns out he's selling out
Madison Square Garden but that's the
relationship people feel with you after
watching you perform they just feel very
connected to you and and they want to
share you you're someone that's people
you're a comedian that people want to
introduce their family to you're you're
getting screened a lot it holidays
you're something you pull up on Netflix
all right and what a great what a great
thing to be know you're very accurate
it's amazing over Thanksgiving and
Christmas I get some yeah yeah we're all
watching you're special and you know why
though I for me it works because it's
kind of clean I'm not doing anything
where grandma might have to cringe yes
watching it so I think it's you know
family-friendly and and the right people
that people like to share it now you're
you're in this movie the green book and
your green book sorry and you're about
to be in
Martin Scorsese's movie is that correct
that's right yeah yeah the irishman
which you've already shot yes and that's
gonna be on Netflix right that's good
you have a substantial role in that I
mean you're becoming a legit dramatic
actor was that ever a goal for you at
all was that even of inkling I wanted to
dip my toe in the film business I just
didn't I didn't know when it was gonna
happen I concentrated so much on
stand-up comedy I didn't really pursue a
film career and then I mean as you well
know you start becoming a little bit
more successful in what you do well and
other doors kind of open over you and
these opportunities the green book and
the irishman where parts I had an
audition for but I kind of got in the
door because of the stand-up comedy a
part of it and I wanted an exercise for
it like if you don't like not it's not
just auditions like you have a little
bit going in well you know what it's
funny because when you don't they don't
know you they don't know your work you
know like when I used to go this is what
I used to hate I used to go to auditions
and casting directors to come out and
call them the guy before me and it'd be
like how's your family they know they
know him and and they're talking like
the guys in there for like a half what
do they have in cake so yeah I would be
like when they call me in it would be
any questions and then boom right into
the material there would be none of that
like okay I can't relate well you just
are sitting there going what am I doing
wrong I don't have any kind of
relationship with these how do you even
make that relation I don't even want
that relation this doesn't seem like a
cool person to even know or get to know
their kid it's it's you think how am I
gonna break through and have that kind
of familiarity yeah and you're hoping
for that just because it's boosts your
confidence if anything so it's nice to
know when you walk into the room
people go oh you know I saw your standup
and then yeah
because it's it's intimidating going
into these rooms especially if you're
not a seasoned act they're trying to get
a dramatic role in a film and you really
have no experience doing it so for me
it's nice to go in the room and have
some type of relationship prior to me
even starting what I'm supposed to be so
nice and a lot of times you know as a
comedian they directors and actors or
whoever's deciding whether or not we're
getting in movies or whatnot they can't
do what we do and they kind of look up
to us as like they do theirs they don't
know what we do is like all we can do
and we wouldn't have it no other way
we just don't know any other skill and
we just worked really hard at that one
but it's very impressive to them so you
go in with if they know who you are as a
comedian it's it feels good yeah it
changes everything when you're when you
become known it does it does it gives
you the confidence and confidence it
gives you kind of room to play in the
room maybe that you didn't have when he
first started this business so yeah
these these parts although dramatic have
comedic moments
although the Irishman really doesn't
have a lot of comedy tell me about that
one because didn't you got you got asked
to audition for that and you had a
choice to send in a tape yeah so they
said you sent in the tape from LA or you
come out to New York City and you dish
in front of the casting director and I
said I'm going to come out to New York
City and audition because when you go
into the room you don't know it's like
this like yeah I want I want the kid I'd
rather be in studio with you guys rather
than like a phoner cuz like the phoner
it's like well you know I don't know
like it when I do Foner's I don't know
if the studio is going oh wrap it up
with this guy here I could tell you know
I'm watching people seeing if they're
interested you laughs you are so I
figured figured if I get into the room
I'll have something to feed off of so I
went and I live in the negative I'm not
a positive person
I'm always I'm always thinking the worst
so when that when I walked in there like
listen you're looking really good
for this part Scorsese saw your standup
he saw a little clip of you
it's basically yours to lose I go that's
it I'm done
I'm not gonna get it I mean if they if
you tell me you got to work to get this
that I'm like I'm gonna show you that
you should hire me if you think I
already should have the job I go to the
other way so I unravel in the audition
don't do well I leave I told my agent
not gonna get a good call on this sure
enough she said man wasn't consistent
enough but have them take my notes put
it on tape and if I like the tape I'll
show Marty so I don't went I put it on
tape she loved it she showed Scorsese he
didn't like me for the part I dition for
he gave me another part so this is one
of those moments where you know just
never give up and I took the notes and
how long did it take you to go okay I'm
happy with that take you know when
you're making a tape for these auditions
that's the other problem with it's
better to do it in person cuz you just
go I did it and I'm done and I can't
redo it tape you can spend all day did
you when do you finally go I'm good well
I did it with my acting coach and I kind
of let her determine okay not she goes
yeah that's that's that's good that's
the ones I don't even like looking at
the audition I don't want to watch any
do you watch your standup I listen to it
I recorded and I listened to it and
every single one at the Comedy Store I
do like the night I saw you I listened
to every single one on the way home to
see what I did I got to start doing that
well I mean what do you mean how do you
how do you gauge whether or not like
just in the moment I remember say that
again try to remember to say that next
time because that was good or you know
I've been doing lately if I say
something on stage that works and you
all I'm gonna remember it but you never
do you know like in the moment you say
it I say hey can you guys tweet that at
me later and I make them feel something
like that's the first time you that I've
ever said that and that was fun I'll be
in my Netflix special but you got to
tweet it at me later and then you have
people tweeting you notes
Wow so you put him to work you live the
audience that's unheard of they love it
it's interactive
[Music]
you